when is the last time you were afraid
I'm afraid every day what are you afraid
of the health and well-being of my
family and I mean for real I'm actually
more scared than almost anybody I know
I've never been scared in business
you're neurotic I'm just genuinely
concerned about the health about being
in my family them dying I love them very
very much I'm being very serious with
you like work never doesn't stress you
out of course not because like being the
best basketball player in the world or
at least an all-star it's what I do it's
what I'm great at it's my natural gift
I always win in that that's a foregone
conclusion whether somebody on the other
side of this lens likes that or not I'm
gonna win professionally what I'm scared
of is when I can't control and the only
thing I care about that I can't control
is the health and well-being of my
family and closest friends and I'm
genuinely scared of it by the way you
are like it's a thing that crosses my
mind almost daily a phone call or text
that isn't interesting at all and you
know what I'm gonna go weirdly the other
way is the driver of my happiness
because every second it's not happening
I'm super pumped I mean it it's very
binary for me
you